The double circle, or rather P1, as it's called in the exam, is two circles
flown in one go — so flown directly connected together. The entry and exit, however, are
on the same axis, or simply parallel to the axis you started on, so
I start on the axis, fly the first circle, the second circle, and the end of the second
circle, the exit, must be parallel to the beginning of the whole thing. Then the
setting and maintaining of a certain bank angle and the ending of that bank angle with energy management,
you could say, summarised.
Okay, I could begin the whole thing flown with the brakes at the knot in the hand.
That means you take both brakes very loosely at the knot in your hand and then try to pull the brakes
down to minimum sink at the very least.
We start the manoeuvre with both brakes pulled to minimum sink.
We always check first, before initiating the turn, that the airspace is clear,
and if that's the case, then we initiate the right circle.
We can now define the bank angle of the circle a bit with the inside brake.
So once we're in the bank, we then simply pull the inside brake slowly down,
moment, and as the wing loses a bit of bank angle, then we may
pull two or three centimetres to set the bank angle better again.
And then just before we've finished the second circle, so just before we're on our
flight line again, we move with the body into the neutral position and then, just before our
flight line, we pull the outside brake down, so that we are theoretically back at minimum
sink. Of course you don't have to pull the brakes that far down — so a bit of brake,
for minimum sink, then exactly the same procedure, left hand up, weight to the right, bank angle
set, defined, then just before we're on our flight line at the end of the second circle,
go to a neutral sitting position, take the hand back down, so that as much as possible we come out of the whole thing
braked symmetrically on both sides. And only then can we transition back into
glide flight. For the double circle, a defined flight axis is taken.
Through measured pulling of the right brake line, two right-turning circles
are flown without interruption within a maximum of 20 seconds. With early slowing of the
turn, the manoeuvre is exited on the original flight axis. Through measured
braking, any following roll and pitch motions are caught and the wing is stabilised.
Important: timing stops only when the wing is flying stable on the original flight axis.
again.